in today's era many organizations run
their software environments in the
amazon web services
aws and a lot of other companies are
also migrating to aws
every day considering that if you're
looking for an aws
job or planning to move to an aws
position
in your current company earning an aws
certification can be a brilliant
investment
aws amazon web service is one of the
leading platforms in cloud computing
amazing web services was founded the
year 2006
and apparently it holds a market share
of 31.7 percent
aws provides approximately 175
fully featured services it consists of
significant benefits like
compute storage databases
networking analytics robotics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
in case you're wondering where do you
begin which aws certification is the
right
choice for you aws provides 12
individual certifications spread across
four different levels
identifying where to start and which aws
certificate
is the best choice for your job profile
can be a little confusing at first
but once you find out what's the right
choice
the path usually becomes pretty clear as
i
already said aws provides 12
certifications
aws certified cloud practitioner
aws certified developer associate
aws certified sys ops administrator
associate aws certified
solutions architect associate
saaco2 aws
certified devops engineer professional
aws certified solutions architect
professional aws certified advanced
networking speciality aws certified
security specialty
aws certified machine learning
speciality
aws certified database specialty dps
c01 aws certified data analytics
specialty
das c01 aws certified alexa skill
builder specialty
you can get a complete understanding of
all learning paths to prepare for the
certifications on the simply learn
aws certifications page
now let us have a closer look at each
certification
let's start with aws certified solutions
architect
it is an associate exam designed for
individuals who are willing to gain
knowledge in designing applications
the associate certification focuses on
the core aws services
like identity and access management
virtual private cloud s3
and ec2 with this certification a
candidate will be able
to design and deploy a cost effective
application on the aws
platform move an existing on-premises
application on the aws platform
submit and retrieve data from the aws
platform identify and define
best practices for the implementation of
aws
architecture estimate aws costs
and identify cost control mechanisms
the fee for completing this
certification
is 150 us dollars and the average salary
and aws
professionals earn after completing this
certification
is one lakh thirty thousand eight
hundred and eighty three dollars
now let's move ahead and know the
eligibility criteria for the
certification
next you should be able to identify and
define
requirements for an aws based
application
aws requires at least one year of
deploying distributed systems at scale
knowledge of at least one programming
language is required
proficiency in hybrid system deployment
using aws components is necessary
provide best aws service for
architecture requirements
next comes aws certified solutions
architect for professional
it was designed for experts who are
willing to enhance their knowledge in
designing
distributed systems and applications on
the aws platform
with this certification a candidate will
be able to learn
the process of designing and deploying a
reliable and cost-effective application
on the aws platform he will be able to
provide appropriate aws services
to develop and deploy an application
based on client requirements
migrating an existing multi-tire and
complex application on the aws
platform he can design
and deploy enterprise level operations
on aws
platform estimating aws costs
and identify identified cost control
mechanisms will become easier
the fee for completing this
certification is 300 us dollars and the
average salary and aws professionals
earn after completing the certification
is one lakh
forty eight thousand four hundred and
fifty six dollars
now let's look at the prerequisites for
completing the certification
first is minimum three years of hands-on
experience in designing and deployment
of aws cloud architecture
earlier this aws certification required
completion of the aws certified
solutions architect
associate certification exam
but since last year this criterion is
not required
however if an individual doesn't have
any experience in aws
we recommend you to prepare for
solutions architect
associate certification first next
the capability of identifying and
assessing cloud requirements
for designing an aws application is
required
now let's discuss aws certified
developer
certificate for associate level it was
designed for beginners to enhance their
skill in creating and maintaining
aws applications with this certification
a candidate will be able to learn
the development process of reliable and
cost-effective cloud solution using aws
choosing an appropriate aws service for
the application
gain knowledge of creating iam
credentials
i and roles etc in aws services
developing code that optimizes the
performance of aws services
used by your application the fee for
completing this certification
is 150 us dollars and the average salary
an aws professional
earn after completing the certification
is one lakh thirty thousand two hundred
and seventy two dollars
you should have a basic knowledge of aws
services
their uses and best practices for the
aws architecture
to earn the salary as mentioned earlier
you must have at least one year of
hands-on experience in the design
and maintenance of aws cloud
applications
knowledge of popular programming
language is required
experience with the development and
maintenance of applications
built for amazon s3 dynamodb
sqs sns sws
elastic bean stock and cloud formation
is important you should be proficient in
the design
development and deployment of
cloud-based applications
using the aws platform moving further
let's discuss
aws certified devops engineer
certification for professionals
this certification is designed for
enhancing knowledge and provisioning
management security and operations of
aws solutions
with this certification a candidate will
be able to understand
implement and automate the security
controls and compliance validations
implementation and management of
methodologies on aws
and continuous delivery systems
determine and deploy metrics also will
be able to monitor
and lock systems on aws
implementation of highly available and
robust systems on aws
platform automate the operational
process with designing
management and maintenance tools
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 us dollars
and the average salary an aws
professional earn
after completing this certification is 1
lakh 37
hundred and twenty four dollars the
eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification are
minimum two years of practical knowledge
in operating provisioning
and managing applications in an aws
environment achievement of aws certified
developer
associate or aws certified says ops
administrator
associate certification knowledge of
other development methodologies
and processes such as agile
experience in testing and automation via
programming
and scripting languages hands-on
experience in co-development for at
least
one high-level programming language
next comes aws certified sysops
administrator certification for the
associate level
this certification is suitable for id
professionals interested in deploying
scaling migrating and managing aws
systems
this aws exam tests your ability
to deploy manage and operate fault
tolerant systems on aws
migration of an existing application on
aws
recognizing and selecting the
appropriate aws service based on compute
data or security requirements
identifying and estimating the aws usage
costs
and cost control mechanisms the fee for
completing the certification
is 150 us dollars and the average salary
and aws professionals earn after
completing the certification
is one lakh thirty thousand six hundred
and ten dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification
are at least one year of hands-on
experience in operating aws based
applications
understanding of provisioning operating
and maintaining aws based
systems identifying the challenges and
implementing aws best practices over the
complete life cycle of a project
ability to identify and define a
solution for aws based applications
moving forward let's discuss aws
certified big data
this certification validates skills of
technical expertise in designing
and managing aws solutions that can help
organizations extract valuable insights
from their data
this exam will teach you how to perform
implementation of core aws big data
services
with best architectural practices simple
techniques to design
and maintain big data services leverage
tools to automate data analysis
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more the fee for completing this
certification
is 300 us dollars and the average salary
and aws professionals
earn after completing the certification
is one lakh
thirty thousand six hundred and ten
dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification
are first you must have an aws account
to follow along with hands-on activities
next aws recommends associate level
certification before attempting the aws
big data
exam it is an advanced and challenging
exam a minimum of five years of hands-on
experience in data analytics
experience in designing and developing a
scalable and cost-effective architecture
to process data
defining and architecting aws big data
services
and their existence in the data life
cycle of collection
ingestion storage processing and
visualization
finally the last criterion is you should
have a basic understanding
of aws services and a fair understanding
of big data
and hadoop concepts next comes the aws
certified security certification
this certification is intended for cloud
security professionals
it allows experts to improve their
knowledge on how to secure the aws
platform with this certification a
candidate will gain
understanding of aws security services
implementation of aws mechanisms secure
internet protocols and data encryption
methods
implementation of aws data protection
and specialized
data classifications ability to make
trade-off decisions about cost
and security based on the requirement
understanding of security operations and
risk
the fee for completing the certification
is us dollars
300 and the average salary and aws
professionals earn after completing the
certification
is one lakh three thousand one hundred
and ninety five dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification
are achievement in any one aws associate
certification
or cloud practitioner certificate more
than two years of hands-on experience in
securing aws workloads
at least five years of it security
experience in designing and
implementing security solutions
next comes the aws certified advanced
networking certification
this certification validates the skills
of id professionals in designing and
implementing
aws as part of a hybrid id network
architecture
the objective of this certification is
to
help an individual to develop and deploy
cloud-based solutions using aws
design and maintain network architecture
for all aws services
implementing core aws services according
to basic architecture
best practices leverage tools to
automate aws networking tasks
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 us dollars
and the average salary and ews
professionals earn after completing the
certificate
is 1 lakh 13 065 us dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification are
basic knowledge of aws networking
technologies and concepts
minimum experience of five years in data
analytics
accomplishing at least one aws
certification
which is solution architect for
associate level sysops administrator
associate level aws certified developer
associate level or cloud practitioner
certification speaking of cloud
practitioner certification
it was intended for individuals who have
basic knowledge in cloud computing
and would like to enhance their
technical skills
this exam tests will teach you the
fundamental security aspects of the aws
platform
along with a shared security model
knowledge of aws services and the common
use cases
ability to explain aws cloud and its
global infrastructure
capability to define principles of aws
cloud architecture
ability to define pricing models billing
and account management the fee for
completing the certification
is 100 us dollars and the average salary
and aws professionals earn after
completing the certification
is ninety thousand five hundred and
twelve dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification
are basic knowledge of id solutions and
services
and their uses in the aws platform
more than six months of experience in
any role
of aws cloud moving further let's
understand what aws certified alexa
skill builder certification is this
certification is designed for
professionals
who are currently in the role of alexa
skill builder
it validates an individual's ability to
build
test and publish amazon alexa skills
this certification will help you gain
basic knowledge such as
how to design the architecture and user
experience
elaborates on the best practices of aws
and alexa security
it helps in understanding the process of
developing
testing and troubleshooting helps in
understanding the skill publishing
process
and along with the alexa developer
console
it consists of skill operations and life
cycles
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 us dollars
the recommended knowledge and experience
required to have before attempting the
certification are
more than six months of practical
knowledge on building alexa skills
using the alexa skills kit
advanced programming knowledge next
comes machine learning
this certification will help you learn
how to implement a suitable machine
learning algorithm for your business
by unlocking new insights this
certification will help you gain
basic knowledge such as choosing an
appropriate
ml algorithm for a given business
problem
finding out appropriate aws service to
implement
ml solutions designing and applying
scalable
cost efficient and secure ml solutions
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 us dollars
the recommended knowledge and experience
required to have before
attempting this certification are
understanding of basic ml algorithms
experience in implementing hyper
parameter optimization
familiar with machine learning and deep
learning frameworks
knowledge of ml model training best
practices
knowledge of ml deployment and
operational best practices
finally we will be discussing the aws
database certification
this certification helps an individual
to learn the process of planning
designing
and monitoring aws database solutions
it validates an individual's ability to
differentiate the essential features of
aws database services
analyze client requirements to create
and suggest
suitable database solutions using aws
services
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 us dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification
are at least five years of experience
with basic database technologies
minimum two years of hands-on experience
on aws services
knowledge of aws cloud-based relational
and nosql databases
a lot of people might be wondering about
the validity of the certification
the certification is valid for only two
years
an individual has to take up the exam
every two years
the reason behind the logic of
recertification is
amazon keeps frequently adding new
features and services to their website
in that case staying up to date is
essential
aws re-certification consists of either
taking a step ahead
that is advancing to the next level of
your certification
which is from associate level to the
professional level
or taking a re-certification test at a
reduced cost
that was all about aws certification
we have come to the end of the tutorial
video i hope it was informative and
exciting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team
will help you solve your queries thanks
for watching
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here